Hey IMAX fans I'm Andrew Garfield and
I'm Emma Stone we are so excited for you
to experience the amazing spider-man 2
in 3d at your local IMAX theater you
know what it is I love about being
spider-man everything Spiderman was born
for hikes the story starts off a Spider
Man being spider-man we wanted it to be
about a spider-man who had sort of fully
coming into his own he was great at
being spider-man he's better at flying
he's better at fighting bad guys Peter
Parker Mary Osborne what comes with that
is that he's also got a much bigger
target on his back nothing is what I
thought it was there are more forces out
to get him and that collision becomes a
huge part of what this movies about we
have plans for you Peter Parker it's
about making some really tough choices
in your life choices that have major
repercussions for Peter Parker just
because of who he is you wanted to be
the hero this I think is the biggest
spider-man movie today the IMAX in
particular is a wonderful environment in
which to immerse yourself in the film we
have we can change the world let's go
catch the spider
there's a very special kind of almost
physiological experience you go through
when you're watching it in IMAX that I
think is uniquely suited to Spider Man
what this movie allows you to do is
literally fly and soar like spider-man
it looks great in 3d but in IMAX it's
it's you know you're you're out of your
seat you need to experience physically
of what does it mean to fly and together
with I must be all ready to share this
experience you just sense of thrill
that's very special